[Applause]
hello everyone thank you for having me
in this beautiful city of Edinburgh so
whether you're no matter what you're
building with Python whether it's web
applications simple scripts or even
machine learning models your choice of
editor is one of the most important
decisions you can make for your personal
productivity and today developers are
choosing visual studio code as the
number one choice on the most recent
stackoverflow developer survey and for a
variety of reasons because it's fast its
lightweight it's free it's
cross-platform and has great support for
multiple languages so I'm the program
manager for our Python developer tools
at Microsoft and I'm here to talk to you
about how you can make the most out of
using Visual Studio code for Python no
matter if you've used it already for
Python used it for other languages or
never even heard of before I guarantee
you'll learn something useful in today's
session so first of all for those of you
who are new to v/s code
what is vs code so it is a free
cross-platform and open source code
editor from Microsoft it's fast and it's
lightweight you can just open any folder
and start working with various files and
as a very rich extension ecosystem
provided by the community and partially
because it's actually one of the largest
open-source projects on github there's a
very active community it's got very it's
got very good built-in support for
JavaScript and typescript including rich
features like intellisense debugging and
source control among other things and I
mentioned the rich extension ecosystem
the part that my team builds is the
Python extension and with the Python
extension you get those same rich
capabilities for Python so with the
Python extension you get intellisense
debugging linting testing and
refactoring and because of the work that
we're doing a Python is actually the
fastest growing language in Visual
Studio code and it's the most popular
extension for Visual Studio code on the
vs code marketplace this extension is
fully open source and was actually
originally created by a member of our
community
Don j-money from Australia who's sitting
here in the front row give a wave to
everyone Don thank you
so we love the work that Don was doing
and we hired him on and put a full team
on the Python extension we first
published it as Microsoft in November
and we've been putting out a new release
with updated features and better
capabilities every single month since
then and so I want to call out a few
other key extensions that I want to make
you aware of before I dive in if you're
coming from other code editors I hear a
lot of people struggle to change their
keyboard shortcuts so there are great
keyboard binding shortcuts for vim
sublime text Emacs and the IntelliJ
suite of products so if you're using
other editors you can install those
extensions to make the transition easier
and specifically for Python developers
there's extensions that add Django
template syntax and Django snippets as
well as Jinja template syntax and flask
snippets I'm not going to show these
today but I just wanted to call them out
before you dive in so for the rest of
the talk I'm going to do a whirlwind
tour of the Python extension and Python
development in vs code we're going to
start with the essentials setting it up
selecting your Python interpreter
editing and running code and configuring
things like linting and refactoring then
we'll go into some more powerful
features like debugging unit testing
tasks and using docker extensions and
then some preview capabilities that you
can try out today including Intel akkad
which we just launched here at the Euro
Python conference visual studio live
share and the new Python language server
that that we released last week so
without further ado let's go ahead and
dive in and start looking with the
essentials of Visual Studio code so if
you want to get started with Visual
Studio code simply go to code Visual
Studio comm and click on the bright
green download square you can hit that
and one thing while it downloads it's a
very quick download you get taken right
to the getting started documentation
this is great documentation I definitely
recommend reading it and for Python
developers you want to move your mouse
over to that little Python link over
there and click on the Python tutorial
which this Python tutorial takes you
through all the basics of getting set up
so if you're very new to it I definitely
recommend going through that tutorial
you'll learn
all the basic features that you need to
get going so after you download Visual
Studio code you'll be taken to a welcome
screen that looks something like this
and as I mentioned before you need to
install the python extension luckily
we've made that easy we've got the
Python link which is right there and you
can just simply click on that to install
the python extension and it will
download and reload you click ok if you
don't like bright blue links you can
also go to the extensions tab in Visual
Studio code where you can search for
Python and you can go to the python
extension right there and install it
another quick thing to call out about
this page here is that we've got a
really good QuickStart set of steps for
getting started and then at the bottom
of that is a link to our Python tutorial
if you're not sure where to find it it's
right there built-in ok so one of the
first things I like to do after
installing Visual Studio code is to put
vs code on the path so that I can load
it from the command line this happens
automatically if you install it on
windows but if you're on Mac or Linux
you need to run a command now to run a
command with visual studio code you
press command shift P or ctrl shift P to
bring up the command palette where you
have all the commands available to you
in vs code in our case we want to type
shell and run the install code command
in path that will allow us to open vs
code from the command line which I'll
show now so let's create a basic
application here with vs code to do this
I usually start by from the command line
create a new folder I will call it make
it our new app and then we'll go into
that folder and then because I put it on
the command line I could just type code
dot and that will open up vs code in
this folder now you don't need to do
that you can also just click the open
folder button here and you file open
folder but I find it very convenient to
launch it from the command line so
building our first app here I like to
just click the new file button and we'll
call this hello dot py press Enter it
immediately gets recognized as a Python
file you can tell that when you see the
Python interpreter
in the bottom left hand corner quick tip
you can click on that interpreter to
change to Python 3 or anaconda or any
other interpreter that you have
installed so we can select that
interpreter there and we can say print
hello euro Python and command s to save
and then to run this we can simply right
click and say run the Python file in the
terminal and then the built in terminal
will pop up and run that file so that
was a quick tour of getting started just
to recap we downloaded from code visual
studio comm
we added code to the path installed the
python extension created a file and ran
it in the terminal now let's do a little
bit more scripting with Python and I
mentioned the stack overflow developer
survey earlier so one of the things that
I like to do as a demo is actually
download the stack overflow survey data
and play with it to poke around in some
of the results so I'm going to create a
new file called stack overflow dot py
and to use the stack overflow survey I'm
going to use the requests library to
download the stack overflow survey and
so I need to install that but instead of
installing that in my global Python
interpreter I'm going to create a
virtual environment this is its some
people get scared by virtual
environments it's a it's a simple and
useful concept it basically creates a
local copy of the Python interpreter
that's local to your application so I
can install packages without affecting
the other applications that I have
installed on my machine so I'll use the
built-in terminal here and I'll run
Python 3 - M - M and that will invoke
the VN module to create a virtual
environment and I'll pass it the
argument end which will put that into a
folder name and so python 3 just
guarantees that I run Python 3 if
there's multiple Python and versions
installed which there are and you can
see that virtual environment was created
here in the BS code File Explorer I can
see that this is simply just symlinks to
the Python interpreter and a local copy
of the site packages folder that I have
here so I can activate this environment
by 10
being source and been activate that'll
activate that virtual environment for me
now if I say which Python 3 you'll see
that when I run Python it runs out of
this this local copy in this folder here
you don't need to activate the virtual
environment with vs code you can
actually have vs code activate it for
you but first I need to reload vs code
with command shift P I'll select reload
window just so it picks up that new
environment that I've put in this folder
and so now when I click on this
interpreter in the bottom left hand
corner that virtual environment will be
available from this virtual environment
list so I select that VM there this time
I'm going to pay attention to this
pilant installation warning here so I'll
install linting tools there so after
I've activated that virtual environment
now Avia's code uses this interpreter
for all the commands that run so it
installed pilant into this virtual
environment if you want to create a
terminal that has this environment
activated you run command shift P and
say Python create terminal and so that
will activate that interpreter
automatically so again if I say which
Python it's running out of that folder
so now I can pip install the requests
library from this command line there and
so now I can start using it in code so
to do that we'll type import requests
now I mentioned I want to download the
survey so I'll create a new request and
say requests dot get and I need the
survey URL so I'll go to the website
where they've published all these
results these are fascinating datasets
to look at by the way they have all
sorts of interesting insights into what
developers are doing and so we paste
that URL and then we say with open we'll
save that into a zip file called survey
2017 zip we'll open this as a writable
file as file and they'll say file dot
write you notice I get this intellisense
as I'm typing here in code request dot
content and we'll go ahead and
right-click and run this piece of code
in the terminal again this time it runs
with the virtual environment that we
have selected in the bottom left-hand
corner and it will download this as a
zip file into my local folder great now
I want to unpack this zip file and I'm
gonna write a bunch of code that takes
the CSV file out of this zip file so I
can start using it but instead of making
you watch me type everything here
they've advised us against doing too
much live coding here at the conference
I'm going to use a feature called
snippets in vs code so I've predefined a
bunch of snippets that I have and I have
one called Esso extract and when I and
it's available in my snippets list and
when I press ENTER that the inserts that
code snippet for me and it pre selects
this survey 2017 field here which I've
defined as a parameter to the snippet so
I can say my survey and I can make that
I can make that a customizable snippet
that I can type in if there's multiple
of those you can tab between all of them
so now I want to run just this piece of
code here that I've typed into vs code I
don't want to run the first part so I
don't run the whole file so I can run
this just the selected piece by
right-clicking and saying a run
selection or line and python terminal or
i can just press shift enter which will
activate that Python interpreter
paste it into the command and you see
that zip file was replaced with the CSV
file containing the survey results
another cool thing you can do with
snippets is you can put variables in
there so I have a to-do snippet that
when I type to do it puts the current
date and I can leave a message for
myself that says refactor this code and
just a quick look at how you actually
edit snippets to go edit snippets you go
file or on Windows it's file but here
it's code preferences user snippets we
select the Python snippets and here's
where we've defined that extract file
snippets it was very easy to put a
variable in you put just this dollar
sign zero and this provides the default
value
so one final thing to wrap this up I
left a to-do here to refactor this code
so let's go ahead and do that so I will
select this whole block of code right
click and say extract method it's going
to prompt me to install the rope library
and I'll select yes so the that we use
the rope package for refactoring so I'll
right-click again after that's installed
and say extract method the find the
method name is download underscore
survey and there we go it's done that
refactoring so just a quick recap we
selected our interpreter we ran the file
in terminal oh I miss linting here so I
have pilot turned on by default but you
notice there's not very many warnings
inside of this piece of code that's
because we have a default set of linter
rules it's very non aggressive the
default pilant warnings can contain a
lot of style information so if you want
to customize your code style for your
team one cool thing you can do is just
check in a pilant our C file so simply
by having the presence of a pile into
our C file we throw away our default
pilot rules here so if I go back and
untap this you'll see it will give me
some warnings here doesn't like the
names of my variables and all sorts of
stuff like that if I want to customize
those warnings I can just put a block in
the pilot RC file that says messages
control and just a quick tip on how to
do this it's very difficult to find the
syntax for this online but you put
disable equals all and then say enable
equals just the categories so you can
say warnings convention or errors in
this case I just want errors and you can
put individual pilant codes which you
can look up online there I'm so if I go
back to the file and now it just gives
me the error and it's telling me that
this download survey method is undefined
great so there's some information on
using virtual environments very useful
another thing you can do with virtual
environments is you can a lot of people
check in a requirements txt file into
their repo so this is a lot enables you
to easily
package up the dependencies that your
Python code has so you can pip install -
our requirements that txt file and you
can generate one of those files using
the pip freeze command and that puts the
currently installed packages into that
file and when you're done you can type
deactivate from the terminal we also
have support for PI in pip end and
content environments and vs codes if
you're using those we support those as
well and they'll just show up in that
interpreter list that I brought up
earlier
alright so let's jump into a few more
powerful features of vs code and for
this I'm going to go through debugging
unit testing and some tasks and a few
keyboard shortcuts so I've got this CSV
file I actually want to analyze some of
the data in the CSV file I'm going to
jump to some code where I've actually
pulled out and some of the information
and done some analysis so I've got this
in a folder called hello Stack Overflow
and just like I did before I'll change
to that folder and type code dot to open
it up you'll see that the folder comes
right up and I've got all my Python
files here so just some quick keyboard
shortcut tips I press command P that
allows me to quickly switch between all
the files in my current workspace I can
switch to the stack overflow dot py file
by the way if you press alt and press
ENTER it'll actually open one of those
files in the right hand vertical tab
window so that's a neat tip if you want
to quickly peek into another file you
can also do that just by clicking this
button here another tip here if you want
to split your editor vertically is you
press the Alt key and it changes that
little icon from a horizontal split to a
vertical split so I can split the editor
vertically there and we can go on so on
and so forth in a recursive manner
another quick tip if you want to open
the terminal
it's ctrl backtick that will open that
terminal up and you can also split the
terminals so you can split the terminal
right so if you want to do something
like have the zen of python up on your
screen down in the terminal you can have
a dedicated terminal window for that
although in the lightening talk on
wednesday they advised against reading
the pipe
zennith Python - seriously you can also
put your terminal on the right-hand side
of your windows if you want which works
better if you're not projecting at the
conference but it's I find that very
useful on larger monitors okay so let's
get back to our previous configuration I
seem to have got myself into a bind here
with these terminal windows let's just
close everything put that back on the
bottom okay so some other shortcuts here
command shift o lets me open various
symbols that I have in the workspace so
you can see as I'm going through this
list I can look at the different methods
that I have so I've basically refactored
my previous code example to download all
years of the stackoverflow developer
surveys back to 2011 there's a method
here which does some analysis of those
Stack Overflow surveys called download
survey so I can press ENTER to look at
that and you can also command click on a
method if you want to go to the
definition on a method so for example if
I want to look at the request get
implementation I can command click and
that will that will open that file
directly there and another quick tip is
you can right click and say peak
definition if you want to quickly look
at the definition of that method in line
okay so aside from just reading the code
let's actually debug this and step
through and see how it works
so to use the debugger it's actually
very simple you just click in the gutter
and select put a breakpoint there that
will have the S code stopped on this
line when we start the debugger and go
to the debug tab and press the bright
green play button another keyboard
shortcut for play is just f5 so I can
press f5 here and it will actually let
me pick my choice of debuggers this is
because we have the next version of a
debugger available as an experimental
version it's much faster it's based on
an open source debug engine called PI
dev D and so this is going to become the
default soon so let's go ahead and use
that
Python experimental version and we'll
run and we'll stop at that breakpoint
right so this just debugs the current
file whatever Python file in that if I
want to debug it just press f5 so now
that I'm stopped at this breakpoint I
can see the variables in the left-hand
side of the window here I can see the
year in various things like that and
this analyzes one your one year of
survey for every iteration of this for
loop so if I want to run one iteration
of this for loop I can click the play
button here the continue button or f5
that will run and that will stop after
its downloaded one year of the
stackoverflow developer surveys so if we
want to actually look at how this code
works we can use the step into button or
f11 so we can step into that code here
and we can press step over to run over
at one line at a time so that line
downloaded the survey and then we
actually here on this line we crack open
the survey CSV file we load it into a
panda's data frame using a panda's
library which if you're not familiar is
a very popular library for data analysis
and data frames so we step over that
line we load the survey and if we
actually look at some of the columns
that are in this CSV file we can type an
expression into the watch window for
example like data columns if you look at
this it contains a lot of internal
information from pandas dataframes so if
we want we can customize this expression
here and say list data columns so we can
just cast it into a list to get rid of
all of the other items and then we just
get a list of columns that are inside of
this data frame this is a little bit
this is not the best window to view this
information so I'm going to switch over
to the debug console here by clicking
this go to the debug console I can also
type expressions in here so if I type
list data columns I can view that here
in the output window and I can see all
of the questions that were present on
the stack overflow survey for this year
you can see the one we're interested in
is the which languages are you
proficient
which are people telling us which
programming languages that they use and
so as we step through our code we want
to extract just this question plus the
related columns that come after it so we
can step over this one line at a time
and you and we're just iterating through
all the columns in the list until we
find the right question I don't want to
sit here and step through all the items
in the for loop so I'm gonna skip past
all of this by using a run to cursor
function so I could set a breakpoint
down here and run to that breakpoint but
I can also right click and say run to
cursor which is kind of like a one time
breakpoint as soon as you hit it the
breakpoint disappears if you actually
looked closely you'd see a breakpoint
briefly appeared there and the editor so
that skips all of that looping and now
we can again look at the languages dot
columns basically what we did was we
extracted the languages into a languages
data frame and we can see that if we
look at languages columns in the debug
console and we can see that this data
frame just has this information in it we
can also see that there's a total of
2,300 people who answered the survey in
this year so that's pretty neat all
right let's pop out using the step-out
function will pop back up the stack to
that outer for loop and we'll let it run
to completion now I don't want to
download all of the surveys with you
guys watching me on the poor Wi-Fi here
in the in this hall so I'm going to use
a task that I have defined that pre
copies cached versions of these files
into my workspace to do that I'll go to
the tasks window and I'll say run tasks
will select these custom shell commands
that I've defined one of them is copy
cash surveys and when I run that the CSV
files magically appear so I can kind of
automate some of the things that I do in
my day-to-day environment with those
custom tasks and then we'll just let
this run to completion and let it
generate the results of these surveys
it'll going to put that out in a JSON
file so if you want to define your tasks
simply go to the tasks configure tasks
window and you can see that it's as
simple as putting shell commands
this also has integration with NPM
so if you have NPM tasks here they will
they'll show up in this list okay so
that data is now available in a JSON
file where I can see for every year how
many people indicated using each
language we can see that Python was used
by five hundred and seventy five people
on the 2011 and stackoverflow survey
that's pretty neat we'll take a look at
this in a second but how do we know that
this data here is correct well we run
unit tests hopefully so I've got some
unit tests defined in this something
someone would shout out the answers but
we've got unit tests defined here in
this test folder so visual studio code
has integration with unit tests if we
want to configure those we're using the
unit test framework but we support
support multiple testing frameworks so
to configure those again we run a
command command shift P discover unit
tests that will prompt us to enable and
configure a unit test framework so we
just click that bright blue button there
and so we can configure unit test PI
tester knows unit tests will go with the
unit test framework it will ask us a
series of questions like where is our
tests folder so we're in our tests are
defined and this tests folder here and
the file convention that we use is test
underscore star dot py so we'll select
that and a really neat feature that we
have with vs code is we have these unit
testing code lenses so this lets us run
one test at a time I can run just the
test for the 2017 survey or I can click
the run test on the entire class so I
can run an entire class of tests and of
course you can run all the tests in your
workspace but after you run the test
what's really neat is that these
indicators actually show you little
check marks and X's when the tests pass
or fail we're not going to worry about
fixing this unit test right now I will
come back to that later but it looks
like or 2017 day is correct but our 2015
data is a little bit off ok so just a
quick recap we just went through
debugging start debugging stepping
inspecting variables using the debug
console typing expressions in using run
to cursor to run to
particular line of code keyboard
shortcuts for jumping to files various
symbols and going definition considering
unit testing and tasks within your
workspace now we're going to do a little
bit of web development and we'll show
you how you set up more advanced debug
configurations for flask and Django as
well as using the docker extension so
this data is currently in a CSV file I'd
like to render this in a nice web page
to do that I'm going to start writing a
web application I'm gonna put my web
application in a folder called app so
here's a neat productivity tip if you
create a new file and you just type a
folder name that you want to put that
file into in this case I want to put a
file in app called main dot py if you
press ENTER it'll go ahead and create
that folder and put the file within the
folder so I've got another snippet here
that'll create a basic flask web
application it's called flask app so
that's something I've defined so this
gives me just the general boilerplate
for creating a flask application and
what it does is simply import the flask
object from the flask module creates an
app object and then defines a homepage
route which returns some index.html so I
need to create this index.html file let
me do that again I'll put that in a
templates folder index.html and a really
cool built-in feature of es code we have
integration with Emmet so if you can
type the exclamation mark here and press
Enter that will generate an HTML
boilerplate template for you including
all the tags that you need for it to
render correctly on mobile devices I
don't know why this isn't default for
HTML but it takes me a long time to find
this so it's built right here in Divi s
code and then we can just start editing
our HTML file ok so I have a I'm going
to switch over to a version of this to
an update to Dockers available let's
skip it for now
I've got to switch over to a version of
this code that has a little bit more
HTML written for me it's called stack
overflow flask
I'll run code dot here and we'll just
take a quick look at what's in this code
in that main dot py I have an API that
returns the data file that we just
generated from that that Stack Overflow
survey analysis and the index dot HTML
has a renders that data with some pretty
charts so if we want to run this file
here just a quick tip you can
right-click on that file and say run
Python file in terminal and that will
again activate the virtual environment
and run that on localhost but I'm going
to actually run this inside of debugger
so no matter where I am in my workspace
when I'm working on a web application I
always want it to start the main dot py
file so to configure that I can go to
the debug tab and I can add a debug
configuration by clicking on this little
settings gear link or this add
configuration button here so let's add a
configuration again we're to use the
experimental debugger because that's
going to be the default one soon and it
adds a default set of configurations
here we have debug configurations for
flask and Django and one of the reasons
that you want to do this is that lets
you set your entry point in our case our
entry point is in the app / main py file
but it also turns on Jinja template
debugging or Django template debugging
for these types of apps so that's a
feature that we do support in vs code
for web developers so once I've got
these different configurations defined I
can pick which one I want so I can I can
continue debugging the current file if I
use the current file configuration or I
can use the flask configuration if I
want it to launch my flask application
so we'll click play there and that will
start our flask application and this
time let's browse to the URL a little
quick tip here if you have a URL or any
file link in your terminal you can press
command click to open that link and it
just it opened the browser and then I
hit the breakpoint right away
so we'll just switch back here and we'll
let it run and there's my simple chart
of the survey data for the past few
years python is actually growing super
fast more than 20% year-over-year now
used by more than thirty eight point
eight percent of developers worldwide so
you guys are all doing great work in
this room okay so it's very common to
use docker containers I was told that
docker was actually launched at at PyCon
so docker is a very popular technology
used by Python developers so let's go
ahead and throw this into a docker
container so to do that I'm going to
install the docker extension into vs
code so we go to the extensions tab go
to the marketplace search for docker and
we install that I have it disabled in my
install so I don't have to download this
live on stage but I'll just click enable
there and after we install that
extension you have to click reload so
now that this extension is installed
into my workspace it adds a few useful
commands so we'll go command shift P to
open the command palette and the the
first command will use is the adductor
files to workspace commands so if you're
new to docker this is very helpful it
puts some predefined docker files in
there for you for different languages
we've got Python Go Java nodejs and Ruby
and net core so we'll use a Python
template here for our docker file and
then it also asks which app we want
which port we want our app to listen on
we'll go with the default port 3000 and
that just puts in some of the useful
docker files that we need and in
particular let's go ahead and take a
look at the docker file and customize
this a little bit so some of the
features that you get after these darker
files have been created is that the
docker extension adds
completions for the docker base images
so I want to actually use a different
base image that loads a flask web server
and so I'm going to change this here
there's one great image out there
created by a docker hub user T Angulo
and you can see I get Auto completions
so these are loading the images that are
available on docker hub for me so I'm
going to select this nginx flask one
because I want to host flask in an
engine X web server so that it's nice
and fast in production ready and I can
pick I get auto completion for the
various tags that are available so I can
easily pick the Python version that I
want to run here so I pick Python 3.6
running in Alpine Alpine is a very small
version of Debian it's really good for
production smaller images make
everything faster and the entire build
tool chain and running at runtime as
well and I'm just going to configure
this image a little bit I'm gonna set
the listen port this is a configuration
variable for that's specific to this
image that tells flask to listen on port
3000 so that it matches the exposed port
there I'll copy the app folder into the
app folder within the docker container
and then I'm gonna comment out these
lines here because the docker container
already has this base image already has
these commands that install to Python
packages we also have commands built-in
if you're using pit BEM for Conda you
can uncomment these versions that'll
help you get your Conda environments
installed or pip and environments or
package is installed there easily so now
that I've set up my docker file I can
run another command called docker
compose up which will it'll build this
image here and it will actually start it
locally running on port 3000 because
that's what's been defined in these
docker compose file here and after I do
that I can go to the docker
tab and I here in the docker tab I can
see all the images that are available on
my machine I can delete manage them and
I can see the docker container here it's
running a really neat thing I can stop
restart remove this container attach a
shell and I can also show logs so just
to prove that we're running locally here
I'm going to use that same control
command click and there is the app
running inside of a docker container
that I've just created using vs code
alright
so now we're on to some exciting new
preview features that we've just
announced now these are things that you
can try today but they're in beta so
we're still learning and experimenting
and fixing bugs in some of these the
first of which I mentioned visual studio
and Teleco twitch we've launched here at
Euro Python and launching at 7:00 a.m.
UK time really was interesting from a
perspective of having your entire team
up at 11:00 p.m. on the u.s. west coast
so that was fun but we're very proud to
announce this this is machine learning
based Auto completions for Python code
and this is based on training on more
than 2,000 public and high quality open
source repos that infers that sorts the
completion list based on your current
code context and let me go ahead and
show you exactly what I mean by that so
if I switch over to a different repo
that I have here called it tell assent
samples will open this up in BS code so
Intel the code is a separate extension
that you can install if we go to the
extensions tab type and tell a code you
got this Wi-Fi will install that Intelli
code extension and that's going to after
I reload vs code we'll take a look at
some various code samples here so the
first thing it does is that actually
prompts you to install the Microsoft
Python language server this is a new
intellisense engine that we've just
released last week so it's a preview so
it's something you do have to opt into
but when we turn that intellisense
engine on and tell the code is able to
use that new intellisense engine to
power some of its results so let's take
a look at a few examples of what this
means so normally when you're getting
completions on things like the file
operator there's you know a few there's
about a hundred items in this list but
the intelecom learning model has learned
and said that these are the most likely
options here that are asterisked so it's
suggest using file dot right so I can do
that and say file dot close is another
suggestion that comes up and this works
great for you know the system modules of
you import OS and type OS dot it's
just common things like OS path get
current working directory if you import
sis in type sista
Arg V and path and standard out and some
various things like that and this works
on a broad variety of applications that
we've trained the the model on so if we
go back to our flask application and we
use the app variable it pulls up app dot
R out as the top of the list here and
we'll go ahead and fill in this code
here and then within the actual method
if I use app dot again it actually gives
me different results because it knows
I'm inside of that route method there so
here it's now suggesting config and send
static file send static file is the one
that we want and let's quickly switch
over to another code example where we do
a little bit of machine learning code
here this is the tensorflow getting
started code from the tensorflow website
so I'm just gonna follow along with the
code samples here if I do TF dot that
brings a variable to the top of the list
and I was finished typing this code here
so float32 that's also in the suggestion
list and if I come down here and use TF
dot again now it's giving me TF dot
place holder as the top item in the list
and TF dot now it's suggesting float 32
so as I'm working through different
sections of this code it's giving me
better and better suggestions and my
favorite example here is if I do T f dot
at the bottom it suggests the global
variables initializer which is at the
top of the list and then right after
that if I use create a tensorflow
session it suggests the session variable
so one of the benefits also if you've
noticed with the Microsoft Python
language server is as I type I actually
get syntax errors live in code so if I
put things like semicolons in it Flags
those right away as different issues and
in general I get much richer
intellisense here provided by the open
source type set definition files so
that's an
other benefits of the language server
okay so that's Intelli code I encourage
you to try it out today personally I
really miss it when I have the extension
turned off so it definitely improves my
personal productivity and the other
thing I mentioned was the Microsoft
Python language server until the code
turns us on by default but if you want
to use just the language server you can
turn that on by going to your
preferences and settings and setting the
Python Jedi enabled to false and one
final demo that I'll share with you
another preview feature is Visual Studio
Live share this is an extension for
Visual Studio code that allows you to do
real time collaborative editing and
debugging with vs code and for this part
of the demo I'm gonna go back to that
unit test that I had that was failing
and I'm going to get a more proficient
developer to help me solve that unit
test and in fact I'm going to ask Don to
help me code that live with me sitting
from the front row and right in front of
us okay so let's go back to that repo
that we had earlier I'm going to get
back to the code example where I had the
that filling unit test
okay so this was that failing unit test
here give it a quick run and so while
that's running I'm gonna install the vs
live share extension so if you install
this extension you just have to sign in
you can sign in with a Microsoft account
to our github account and then you can
easily generate a sharing link from your
workspace so the share button has now
appeared on the bottom of my window and
if I click it it's going to copy a
sharing link to the clipboard and then I
can go and chat and say Don please help
and so Don can just go click that link
and that will actually stream all the
files from my workspace over to him and
just for a quick idea of what this looks
like on his side I have a video recorded
where this link pops up and he can click
on that link that opens the
collaboration session on his machine and
just by clicking that link it will open
up vs code on his side and it actually
streams all the files into a Visual
Studio Live share workspace so he
doesn't need to have a copy of the code
and he can actually go and look at the
code and he gets all the intellisense
and features like that working so now
that I see Don's joined my collaborative
session I can actually see where Don's
cursor is this is done right here in
this little yellow link Don why don't
you go ahead and take a look around in
code so he's gonna looked at some other
file here and I can follow him by
clicking this little button here and say
follow Don j-money and so he's scrolling
around and looking at the code he can
highlight text and look at interesting
things and you know no hands over here
so he's he's seeing some interesting
stuff he's getting familiar I can
actually go off and look at different
code then he's looking at so we can get
a good sense of the code base we could
also do some collaborative debugging so
I'm gonna start debugging this unit test
that I have this
we're gonna land right at that break
point that I've just set there so let's
give us a second all right
so Don can actually now control the
debugger right so he can step through
code he can step down into that method
and he can go down to the bottom here
and he can actually see if he can fix
this unit test for us so he set a
breakpoint
there he says this looks interesting and
if you put a blank line here right so
he's put a piece of code in there which
I can then take and if we rerun our unit
test quickly here we'll see that he's
now fixed arguing a test for us
here we go thanks Don for fixing my bug
so that was BS live share get the vs
live share extension and start doing
pair programming and code reviews with
your co-workers and that concludes all
the tips and tricks and features in this
talk you can get productive with vs code
today I just go to code visual studio
comm and for more information about what
we're doing with the vs code extension
or anything fourth python and microsoft
including python and visual studio and
python and azure check out our python
blog codes and slides are available up
here at this repo and follow us on
twitter thank you so much for having me
here this is just a wonderful conference
and I really love this city thank you
[Applause]